good morning
um it's very good to welcome Professor
gnome lubel and Dara Murray and Georgia
Hines were looking at you remotely I
take it you're probably in Geneva is
that correct
correct yes very good well we'll move
around the committee uh covering
particular areas of interest but
obviously members are free to pursue
follow-ups and if you want to add to
answers later on you're free to do that
the session this morning is being
webcast and the transcript will be taken
which you can check for factual accuracy
we our plan to go on till about noon but
let's just see how we go and if I Can
Begin by saying because this is our
first public session at which the house
requires us to declare any interests we
may have mine is quite remote but one of
my sons-in-law as a consultant has done
work for the icrc so that's I've put
that on the record
uh let me Begin by asking you I suppose
a sixty four thousand dollar question
which is how do you define
AWS and why is it why is it important to
do so
well it's an interesting question in
that I I'm not entirely convinced we
should be defining them for the purposes
of of these debates we can there are
lots of different definitions and
sometimes uh Allied states end up having
different definitions themselves which
is part of the problem I think there are
four reasons I would actually say we
maybe should not be rushing to Define
them the first is I think it's very
difficult to have a definition that
wouldn't include existing systems and
systems that have been in use for
decades all sorts of Active Radar homing
or high-speed anti-radiation missiles
that have been in use since the 80s
would actually fit a lot of the
definitions that are being bandied about
right now which would complicate things
I think also the definitions tend to
place too much
emphasis on autonomy rather than the
artificial intelligence elements and
autonomy doesn't equate with an
intelligent system you could have a dumb
autonomy You could argue that a landmine
is a form of an autonomous system but
our concerns aren't really so much with
the autonomy as they are with the AI
That's that's driving a lot of these
systems and you could equally have an AI
driven system that is not entirely
autonomous that is supervised but raises
all the same problems that I think we
want to discuss so I think it's the AI
is more important the autonomy the third
reason I'd say is
that autonomy is a characteristic eye to
just one function within a system so the
system might not be classed as
autonomous but it still may have
autonomous functions uh and again I
think that makes it difficult to just
say a system is autonomous and the last
point I'd make on this is that we're
talking about a very uh fast-paced field
where things are changing all the time
and any definition we tried to come up
with now if we made a hard and fast
definition we'd have all sorts of
systems that fall outside of it within
probably a very short time frame so I
think
at the end of the day we need to be
focusing on particular characteristics
of of systems
but uh and look at the the how they
apply to different functions of the
systems but I'm not sure that trying to
find autonomous systems as a whole and
then apply everything to that is the
right way to go through it is is the
logic of what you're saying that if
we've got this rather sort of leaky set
of definitions of AWS and autonomy that
actually in order to arrive at a working
definition which will be reasonably
robust against developments we need to
have a much more constraining concept of
what AWS is
so I think rather than trying to sort of
have uh the these these specific
definitions I think we need to come up
with basic
um
basic principles guidelines and rules
that apply to whatever systems we use
regardless of how we Define them
I think that would be the way to go um
and and and also to keep in mind that
and again the definitions keep talking
about weapons but some of the concerns I
might not be with the the targeting
element of these systems it could be
with earlier stages in the targeting
cycle with identification of objects and
so on so so again I I I would much
prefer that we we spoke about particular
characteristics problems that come up
with AI and apply them across the
targeting cycle rather than try and sort
of talk about autonomous weapon systems
as a thing
thank you very much can I bring in uh
Dara Murray and Georgia Hines and then
look to Lord brokard for a supplementary
now of course um go first I agree very
very closely I think my main concern
with the definitions I've seen of
autonomous systems is that they're
potentially overly narrow so if we think
of the targeting cycle that's the the
identification the selection and the
engagement of the target often when we
think of autonomous weapon systems they
do all three components so you think of
something like a drone that's deployed
to the battlefield you know to identify
enemy tanks and engage them that tends
to be what we think of when we think of
an autonomous weapon system but as I
think Noam was talking about
in the future well particularly in the
future the military is going to be an
interconnected military with lots of
different sensors drawing on a wide
variety of data points data sources and
that's going to be characterized by
pervasive AI across that entire system
so one of the things that will
inevitably arise is that AI may be used
to identify a Target you know to draw an
intelligence and identify it that would
then be passed to a targeting Matrix and
then selected for engagement but the
only autonomous component might be an
identification you know entirely
slappers it's a it's a normal fighter
jet that attacks the Target so I think
avoiding an overly narrow definition is
really really important
thank you uh Georgia Hinds
thanks very much so
um on this the icrc has put forward a
definition
um including in the CCW and that's been
picked up by a number of states and
aligns quite closely with proposals by
the UK so the definition that we put
forward is a weapon system that selects
and applies Force to targets without
human intervention so I think uh I agree
with the comments that have been made
but it's definitely appropriate to take
a functional approach so we're basing it
on the process by which the force is
applied rather than tying it to
technological specifics and we agree I
agree with um both uh what's been said
and with the UK government position that
tying definitions to technology would
absolutely risk them becoming redundant
very quickly I think for us our
definition does extend to cover certain
existing weapons so things like air
defense systems on warships
um active protection weapons on tanks
and a mine would fit our definition as a
very rudimentary autonomous weapon
system and I think this demonstrates
that for us the definition doesn't
require complex technology so it is not
a defining feature that an AWS
incorporate AI it might but it doesn't
necessarily the key point for us and
what raises the most concerns from a
legal and an ethical perspective is that
after the weapon system is activated by
a person then it's the system that
self-initiates or triggers a strike or
application of force and it does this
responding to environmental information
so it receives this through its sensors
and it has a generalized Target profile
that's been input at the activation
stage
the the difficulty there for us and what
is at the root of most of our legal and
ethical concerns
is that the user isn't choosing or
doesn't even absolutely know the
specific Target the precise timing the
location of that Force application
and for us this makes a really
fundamental difference between an AWS
and some of these other types of AI
enabled systems so something like an AI
enabled decision support system that is
just providing uh intelligence
information or or something that then
feeds into the targeting cycle but it
doesn't displace those critical
functions of selecting and attacking the
Target so I think that where I suppose I
would differ is that firstly I don't
think it's problematic that our
definition captures current examples
because
there's sort of two definitions that
need to occur firstly you capture all
systems all autonomous systems that may
raise humanitarian concerns and that
need to be regulated so that's based on
this idea of them selecting and
attacking targets which is very very
different from these non-autonomous
systems
and then within that you have the
definition of certain types of
autonomous weapon systems that might
require specific prohibitions
so for us then we move to the the
smaller category of well unpredictable
autonomous weapon systems ones that
don't allow humans to control their
effects that would be a category of
prohibition for us or autonomous weapon
systems that are designed and used to
apply Force against persons
but all the other ones that are
currently within use that don't fall
within those smaller prohibited
categories I think are subject to
General regulations constraints on use
that are already being input around
duration location
um the types of targets they're
primarily being used only against
against military objectives by Nature so
things like incoming projectiles enemy
equipment things that are much more
stable in their characterization
rather than sort of you know civilian
objects that might be used temporarily
for say a hospital is is used
temporarily as a base thank you very
much um can I ask you to keep your keep
your answers fairly short because yes
sorry we've got quite a lot of ground to
cover and when we um we can pick up that
issue of Regulation and constraint in a
moment because I know that Lord Clement
Jones has got some questions on that uh
Lord groquott It's been covered oh
yes very much so in that case
um on this little brown I just I mean
specifically on this I mean I mean I I I
like so since I haven't spoken I I'll um
through my interests so I I'm the vice
chair of and a consultant to the nuclear
threat initiative
um a director of both the European
leadership Network and the asia-pacific
leadership Network the working arms
control matters and a member of what to
my embarrassment is called the group of
eminent persons of the comprehensive
test management organization and and a
member of the top level group for
multilateral nuclear non-proliferation
and I'm very proud to be an ambassador
of the hill of trust so
um I mean on this issue of of definition
I mean I mean first of all I mean it's
an observation we have to have a
starting point I mean I mean I think
it's very clear uh from what we've been
doing in preparing for this the issues
that we are concerned about are pretty
clear and they are highlighted I think
by Miss Heinz
um evidence to it so if we don't start
with some definition because we're all
legislators and then where do we start
so and and if we come into an
environment in which
you know the U.S Department of Defense
NATO
Human Rights Watch The International
commission for Red Cross author of
definitions we can't just ignore them
you know so we need some assistance as
to where we start with this and
and I mean I put this in the form of a
question these are not sensible for us
to start where everybody else is
which is struggling to find a definition
Professor lubel I'll give you first
crack at that uh
so I'm not sure there is a place where
everybody else is uh there are different
definitions out there we've even seen at
times between the US and the UK so
significant differences to the point
that you know one is saying we use them
but only with human supervision and the
other saying you know we wouldn't we
don't have them and we would never use
them talking about the same systems now
that has changed and the definitions of
including the US and the UK have have
developed uh with with time but I I
would say that
um one can certainly talk about the use
of and again I wouldn't limit it to
weapons I would say the use of AI in a
targeting cycle use of AI in military
operations I would have something around
that as my starting point rather than
defining particular weapon systems
because and I think this came out with
with actually all of the comments
artificial intelligence can play a
critical role in who or what ends up
being targeted even outside of a
particular weapon and and there's
actually a risk if what you're concerned
about I would say is is some of the
dangers that could happen actually
having some of these using some of these
definitions that are out there could
actually limit the ability to address
some of these concerns
uh Daryl Murray who
um in agreement with that yeah I am I
think the danger with the current focus
with the definition is that it focuses
tension on something that's
um kind of quite Sensational I guess you
know it's the Terminator style
um autonomous weapon system that gets
deployed and selects targets and engages
on its own and maybe that's only a very
small subset of potential systems and as
no one was saying it's the use of AI
across the military that's maybe of more
concern so the danger with the current
definition I think is that it just
misses an awful lot of really important
issues
Coventry before I ask Ms Heinz for her
view on that
Christopher Christopher concert Bishop
of Coventry I I can't think of any
relevant interests that I have to
declare
um
to my I think my question is simply
whether
um this more sophisticated
um concept of definition that you're
talking about does that provide the sort
of basis that
um international law can work with in
the way that
um Georgina Hines was suggesting
is needed at some point both in terms of
Regulation or even prohibition
it's not some sort of fairly well
defined agreed definition necessary for
lawmakers
depends what you want to apply it to I
think if you're trying to create a new
legal instrument for example that
applies to a particular category of say
weapons then absolutely you have to
Define them and and and any any
instrument that's dedicated to a
particular set of weapons you know has
some form of a definition but if and I
would suggest uh perhaps the the uh the
more practical
help us going into the future if what
you're trying to do is to say well these
are the types of Technologies that's now
being used we need to clarify certain
aspects of international law and in
particular International humanitarian
law that would apply to any weapon
system or apply to to all they apply to
all and however you define autonomous
weapon systems and other things as well
these these particular rules need to be
clarified in terms of what level of
human involvement human supervision do
you need and you know there's no problem
saying it applies to other weapons that
aren't AI weapons that fit outside this
definition as well because the these be
things that apply across the board so I
my starting point would be say these are
the technologies that are coming out
these are the how this is how they're
going to be used let's clarify
international law to make sure that the
existing principles and rules are
understood in a way that we can use them
in these weapons and address the
concerns that come up these weapons but
they would apply across the board they
don't require us to come up with with a
specific narrow definition right now of
autonomous weapon systems can I just
asked you Georgia Hines if she wants to
comment on that then I'll go to Lord
Cameron and then Lord Horton
thanks very much uh so I I do think this
issue about uh there is definitely a
risk with definitions that are too
narrow and and I think we need to be
mindful of that uh in the sense that
then any prohibitions any regulations
that are developed uh even any policies
wouldn't have a meaningful impact in
addressing the very real humanitarian
and legal and ethical concerns and I
think we've seen that with some Notions
like fully autonomous weapon systems or
autonomous weapon systems completely
outside human control they definitely
seem to run this risk of I think what
was referred to as this uh Fantastical
Terminator scenario but we very much
support the idea of a baseline
definition from which to then build on
recognizing um that we we do call for
new rules rather than simply a
clarification of existing IHL so I'll
leave it there thank you uh to a little
Fairfax to Cameron with apologies for
having misnamed him earlier on
I'm often called lord Halifax so that's
a change thank you
um so I just
um first of all may I declare I have one
interest I'm the co-owner of a private
security company
um called Hawkeye worldwide Limited
um but I I've got quite a narrow
question actually was just picking up on
your point about targeting and I was
just thinking in the scenario where
you have you know the targeting is done
by AI
and then there's a human in the loop
afterwards
so uh and so in that scenario so the the
AI says we're good to go
um but it's then for a human to decide
whether to accept that recommendation so
would that fall out of therefore uh the
consent because you were you were
talking you were you were very much
talk about targeting and I was just
thinking about that situation where
after the recommendation from the AI you
have the human making the actual
decision decision
absolutely well
yes I mean I I think this is something I
don't feel if you're planning to run
through all the questions it's something
that comes up also
um later in uh with regard to one of the
questions of
um
of some of the problems that may arise
but
just briefly I'd say there is a real
issue over understanding what we mean by
human involvement human I mean there are
different phrases use human in the loop
human on the loop uh by the way if
you're thinking about future
Technologies we
including in the UK and the US people
are working on brain computer interfaces
that place human in the loop physically
plugged into the system I mean these
things are happening and what you know
is is that enough or not where do you
place the human
um and this is something that the mod
has spoken about so context appropriate
human involvement so at what stage does
that come do you need a human at every
stage or not I I I think I mean that
this I think this is a theme that's
probably going to come up quite a bit in
in our next discussion but it's
absolutely something that one needs to
be aware of where where is the human
placed will the human automatically
trust the system there are deep
sociological psychological uh and and
other aspects around that as well
may I have follow-up question and it's a
bit of a bit of a odd one perhaps but
I'm just thinking of the the self
um driving
situation you know big you see at the
moment you know whether you have
robocars
and I wonder where this is applicable at
all to the situation that we're
considering
so it is thought that robocars may in
fact be
um much safer than cars driven by humans
they may reduce the accident rate to I
don't know a fraction of one percent
rather than
whatever it is at the moment but the
fact
that they are driven by artificial
intelligence means that
we humans expect them to be 100 percent
uh I'm sure you understand what I'm
trying trying to say and I'm just
wondering whether that analogy is at all
applicable to our scenario where you may
have it may be the fact that it's an AI
deciding in the end whether to push the
button or not
is unacceptable whereas in fact let's
say the locality rate or the risk of
bad decisions May in fact be much
smaller
yeah I think
the fact that it is an AI is probably at
the Crux of the heart of the issue and I
think maybe that's the icrc's objection
to the idea that the AI targets
individuals
um I don't think from a legal standpoint
but there's maybe that there is
necessarily a distinction you know
somebody is targeted legally it's
whether it's in compliance with IHL or
not and I think there is a possibility
that AI could produce far better results
um you know it can take a lot more
information into account it doesn't
suffer from fatigue or from adrenaline
or from Revenge so if it's designed
properly I don't see why it couldn't be
better in some instances I think for me
the
the big stumbling block is that we tend
to approach an AI system kind of from a
one-size-fits-all perspective where we
expected to do everything but if we
break it down in certain situations you
know maybe identifying an enemy tank or
you know responding to an incoming
rocket and AI system might be might be
much better
Georgia Hines do you want to come in on
that
I will thank you so I think um this
comes up a lot about the potential for
autonomous weapon systems to improve
compliance with IHL and definitely I
understand that autonomous weapons can
offer potential military benefits over
Direct Control or remotely controlled
and so the increased speed operation in
communication denied environments
um but I think uh first of all we'd be
very much caution against conflating
potential military benefits with IHL
compliance or humanitarian compliance
now something like speed actually can
pose a real risk for compliance with IHL
so if human operators don't have the
actual ability to Monitor and to
intervene in processes if they're
accelerated Beyond human cognition it
means that they wouldn't be able to
prevent an unlawful or an unnecessary
attack and that's actually an Ito
requirement
um I think I think this point about
um the the fact that artificial
intelligence or autonomous systems are
not subject to rage and revenge and
fatigue
first of all the argument like with
self-driving cars at the moment actually
lacks empirical evidence
instead what we're doing is engaging in
hypotheticals where we compare a bad
decision by a human operator against a
hypothetically good outcome that results
from a machine process and I think there
are many assumptions made in this
argument not least of which is that
humans necessarily make bad decisions uh
It ultimately also ignores the fact that
humans are vested with the
responsibility for complying with IHL so
they are the ones that
be held accountable if they don't and
there are processes for this so I think
there are there are many assumptions
made in that um on the incorporation of
AI into other decision support systems
so feeding into but not replacing the
targeting process I think we agree that
this can bring greater information a
greater situation of awareness which
could as as has been said under the
right conditions um accounting for
things like automation bias could
produce good results but again I would
make a separation between those systems
that are feeding in but not replacing
the ultimate human decision in targeting
and autonomous weapon systems because I
think they do fundamentally raise
different legal considerations thank you
very much
um I go to Lord Horton and then we'll
move into the related question which you
touched on already of Regulation and
constraint so Lord Horton
um just in terms of my interest at
being an ex-chief of Defense staff and
then multiple interests either being the
chairman of or an advisor to a range of
defense and security businesses which
use AI in their products and I'll just
list them drarken secure Cloud plus tall
as UK Tanda web white space and
Rebellion defense
um
my question was perhaps a bit convoluted
but does humanitarian law always proceed
from the assumption that a human
decision is better than a machine
decision
or is it the fact that
there's always got to be the
accountability of a human in the chain
of Delegation of a decision
and might it be a plausible scenario
that a human being could delegate to an
autonomous machine the deciding
um the decision ability
even and still remain liable in the
event of that turning out to have been a
bad choice
can you unpick where
I
Claude
many of them precede arrival on the
battlefield I have to say
um so to try to sort of pursue some
element of perfection in all this
could be a bit dancing on a pin
some of the reasons you've absolutely
said that the better decision when there
is a Time imperative and and there is no
collateral risk and all that sort of
Delegation is a far better option to
another autonomous system or we forgo
all the benefits of technological
advancement in this particular area
Could you
um perhaps I've ever comment on any of
that
right who's going to go first
professor lubell
well there's a lot in there
so
firstly just
um on sort of better decisions or not
better decisions I I think I think it's
important also to
um and to acknowledge I agree with what
our colleague from the icsc said in
terms of better for whom and the
military side and the humanitarian side
might not always
in this sense see the same thing as
being better I do think that you know
speed was mentioned but accuracy for
example is one where both I think on
both sides of the equation the military
and the humanitarian you can make an
argument that accuracy is a good thing
um and and so for example if these
systems are are more accurate
that might be a reason there may be a
humanitarian reason to use them but
we've seen some of these debates play
out uh similar to the questions are
being asked now with a Precision weapons
that sort of emerged over the last uh
decades uh and and you can see that on
the one hand there's an argument being
made oh will there be less collateral
damage you know so it's better to use
them but at the same time one could also
argue that that also led to carrying out
Military strikes in situations where
previously it would have been unlawful
because there would be too much
collateral damage now you carry out a
strike because you feel you've got a
Precision weapon and there is some
collateral damage albeit lawful but had
you not had that weapon you wouldn't
have carried out the strike at all so so
sort of there's there's a two sides to
to this coin in terms of the delegated
to uh to these systems I think part of
the problem is how we discuss and debate
this uh so we're talking about uh what
um and you know I'm not a technology
expert myself but but you know probably
enough I know enough to say there's a
difference in what called General
artificial intelligence and narrow
artificial intelligence we talk about
systems that uh that are created to
perform a particular task they're a tool
right it's not the sort of the
Terminator scenario of the general
artificial intelligence of of you know
something that sets its own
tasks and goes about achieving them and
so the systems that we're talking about
don't decide
right that you know in that sense we're
using language that's that is sort of
the human language for for a tool it
executes a function but it doesn't make
a decision in that sense and so yeah I I
personally am not comfortable with the
idea even the sort of we're delegating
anything to it this is a tool just like
any other tool all weapons are tools and
we're using a tool we and in that sense
from an accountability perspective
um I don't know if you if if you want us
to get into the whole accountability
question now
um or or later I think we will later yes
but I think there are solutions to the
accountability uh problem that are based
on understanding that these are tools
rather than agents
yeah I agree I think that's really
important and IB also hasn't in this
context of using the word delegation I
think we have to remember that humans
set the parameters for deployments so I
think the tool analogy is a really
important one you know we should be able
to set the types of activities that a
tool will Undertake and that's where the
bounds of responsibility and
facilitating IHL compliance come in and
I think thinking of it as general AI is
maybe that's what we were saying earlier
I think maybe a little bit distracting
from the the more likely deployments
we're going to face and the short to
medium term
the signs have you got anything to add
to that
thanks I I will add a uh just a point on
the Precision argument
um so again we hear you know autonomous
weapon systems often equated with being
more precise or more accurate I think we
struggle a little bit with this argument
because the use of an autonomous Weapon
by its definition reduces Precision
because the user actually isn't choosing
a specific Target they're launching a
weapon that's designed to be triggered
based on a generalized Target profile or
a category of object
I think the reference to Precision here
generally relates to the ability to
Better Home in on a Target and maybe to
use a smaller payload but that isn't
tied specifically to the autonomous
function of the weapon so we spoke about
Precision guided Munitions I mean
there's nothing in our definition that
is capturing those that's to do with
incorporating better guidance systems
such as GPS or laser guidance and and
that doesn't mean that you have autonomy
in the function of selecting and
attacking the target necessarily you can
have a remotely
um you know a remotely piloted system
that has exactly those same Precision
benefits so I I think that we should be
careful confusing
um those kinds of precision systems with
necessarily uh what an autonomous weapon
system as I said it could incorporate a
landmine which is definitely not a more
precise weapon
um on the IHL obligations and and the
question of what they require choir of
individuals there are certain IHL
obligations that are specifically
directed to persons so I mean it's
difficult to get around that but then
even more broadly IHL assessments
fundamental assessments such as
distinction proportionality they rely
very much on value judgments and context
so when you recognize someone is
surrendering when you have to calculate
proportionality it's not a numbers game
it's about what is the military
Advantage anticipated
algorithms are not good at evaluating
context they're not good at rapidly
changing circumstances and they can be
what's called quite brittle
so I think in those circumstances
I would really query how we're saying
that there would be a better outcome for
IHL compliance when you're trying to
codify qualitative assessments into
quantitative code that doesn't respond
well to these elements so I'll leave it
there and we can discuss the other let
me just pick up on on compliance because
I'm going to be in Lord Clement Jones on
the issues of Regulation and constraint
and in that context perhaps come back to
Lord Brown in a moment
love uh thank you very much chair
um I declare an interest as chair of the
Council of uh Queen Mary University of
London
um I'm I'm going to ask about the um uh
what regulations or limitations on use
may be needed but um we've already seen
a bit of a Divergence between in a sense
uh What uh actual uh uh uh problems
major concerns
um uh we're talking about because I
think there's more of an emphasis from
uh professor lubel and and uh Dr Murray
uh uh there's more of an emphasis there
on AI and more of an emphasis from
Georgia Heinz on uh autonomy on AWS
basically so I in a sense I need to ask
a a two-part question uh even in that
respect so uh Georgia Hines could you
tell me what your major concerns are in
respect of this uh technology
of course so I think I've already
touched on some of these legal
perspective concerns but
um because you do have these
context-specific uh judgments and IHL is
directed at humans we're concerned about
the ability for an autonomous weapon
system to facilitate compliance of the
user with their IHL obligations
IHL is about processes not just results
so you might have an attack that in fact
causes excessive incidental civilian
harm but if the commander or the
decision maker went through the
proportionality assessment in good faith
and they used the information that they
had and a reasonable Commander would
have made the same decision then the
attack could still be lawful even if the
circumstances changed and affected the
end result so I guess what I'm saying is
that it is about human judgment and it
is about a reasoning process and these
can't be outsourced we also have ethical
concerns so
um the concern about effectively
substituting life and death decisions
with a machine process and we held an
expert meeting on this in 2017 with
independent ethicists and and other
fields and we published a report that
confirmed clear challenges around the
loss of human agency in the use of force
moral responsibility and human dignity
and these are concerns that are
complementary to the legal concerns but
they're actually additional too I think
they're often ignored because maybe the
experts like myself are not ethicists
and are perhaps a little bit
uncomfortable talking about these things
but it's worth noting that ethics often
drives the development of international
humanitarian law and international law
more broadly so this is not a unique
case that we're seeing here
I'll come back to you about what
regulations or limitations on use may be
needed but perhaps I could ask Professor
lubel uh the the question certainly
thank you uh
uh so from a from a legal perspective
legal concerns I think I think sometimes
we're conflating uh technological
challenges and legal ones so the example
of proportionality for uh you know as
I've said absolutely
certainly right now we can't envisage
any AI system that can do the
proportionality balance right so in
proportionality as as I'm sure some of
you know on the one side you're putting
the the uh the concrete and direct
military advantage that you anticipate
and on the other side you're putting the
the collateral harm the harm to
civilians and civilian objects that can
be expected and then you balance the two
right so as has been said you know that
balancing is is at least for the time
being something that we cannot imagine a
machine uh doing we do have ai systems
that can calculate one side of it and
they do that already you've got all
sorts of you know collateral damage
estimation tools and uh and so on where
we use these systems but but balancing
the two we we leave to to humans but
that's a technological challenge I don't
see that as a legal problem the
technology can't do it so clearly it
would be unlawful to use it right and so
so I think sometimes we we're sort of
you know raising technological problems
and saying there's a legal one it's not
a legal problem technology simply can't
do it therefore you can't use it for
that purpose you use it for other
purposes possibly and and I think lots
of the concerns that I would have uh
right now I think that
um I think generally speaking trying to
clarify how technology is at least in
the foreseeable future going to be used
and how the existing rules apply I think
that to me is is is the way to do it
um I I don't see I'm not particularly
worried about the the the UK or
like-minded States right now rushing to
release systems that select and lethally
engage their own targets uh in in that
sense but I I think other states might I
think non-state actors are going to be
making great strides in this field as
well I think that also means that
ultimately we're going to see and this
is part of the concern some form of an
AI arms race uh and uh partly because
you you may need AI to defend against Ai
and uh and and any arms race can be
erased to the bottom but
um I think right now now the concern is
less about a system that you're just
going to sort of release in the wild and
it's going to choose what and who to
attack I still would go back to earlier
comments where the way AI is used in the
earlier stages of the targeting cycle in
detecting and identifying for example
objects of Interest military objects
because we know this already from the
law enforcement area where where my
colleague here has worked quite quite a
lot on problems of of bias and other
issues that have come up in using AI uh
in in for law enforcement purposes and
if those problems repeat themselves when
we're using AI in the earlier
intelligence analysis and and targeting
object identification stages I think
that's where we are at least in the very
near future in terms of problems that
can arise from the use of AI that we
really need to keep our eye upon and do
your concerns mirror those of uh
Professor lubel's Dara Murray to a large
degree I think I have a couple of others
um I'd endorse very much the a life
cycle you know that we interrogate how
AI applies across the entire life cycle
rather than just focusing on an element
and also agree that I don't think the
the problems are necessary with the law
itself but other ensuring legal
compliance and ensuring that we
understand the technology and how it
works and how that can match to legal
requirements and I think they're one of
my main concerns is that how we
acknowledge the characteristics of an AI
system are an autonomous system you know
in terms of how it works so it typically
works on the basis of you know
correlation and organization and
essentially a probability score so you
know it's an inference that an object is
a tank or an inference that an
individual is a member of an armed group
based on a variety of of different
sources and it's really understanding
how those work so that we can apply them
to to IHL rules that'll be key I think
that is it's very value value heavy and
it is context dependent
I think one of the things to acknowledge
I guess is that that decision is made by
humans at the moment but it's also an
imperfect decision you know I think
we've seen a lot of issues where there's
been errors made say particularly with
the classification of an individual as a
member of an armed group or not and so
it's it's about better understanding how
we can acknowledge the the
characteristics of an AI system or the
tools and ensure legal compliance on
that basis thank you very much and just
coming I mean this is a one of the big
questions that we've got to try and uh
get to grips with but would you like to
make a start
um uh Georgia on regulations or
limitations on their use that may be
needed to address uh your concerned and
and possibly those expressed by the
other uh members of the panel as well
I'd love to icrc always loves to have a
go at
assisting with laws and regulations so
our recommendations and they've been
made in the CCW and elsewhere are the
states adopt new law at the
international level so first of all to
prohibit certain categories of
autonomous weapon systems so the first
one is unpredictable autonomous weapon
systems and what I mean by that are
systems that are designed or used so
their effects can't be sufficiently
understood and we've heard already about
the need for understanding but also that
they can't be predicted or explained and
this is most likely to arise with those
systems that are incorporating AI
particularly machine learning and they
can exhibit what's it's called the black
box effect I'm sure some of you are
familiar where their functioning is
opaque so because these systems don't
allow the user to control or limit the
effects which is a requirement of IHL
for us these should be prohibited
then the next category is a Prohibition
against those systems that are designed
or used to Target humans and this is
both a legal and an ethical concern
coming back to that complex judgment
that's needed for a person in armed
conflict whether they are protected so
whether they are
surrendering or whether they are order
combat or out of the fight in some way
whether they are wounded or sick these
are very context dependent they are
things that rely on causation on
intention and not well recognized by the
machine algorithms so they also are
something that changes very rapidly so
we really struggle to see how an
autonomous weapon system could be used
to allow a user to comply with the iho
requirement of Distinction picking up on
gnome's point about technological
changes the other basis for this
prohibition is actually vehicle and as I
said before that is something additional
to the law it is not something that can
be fixed with a technological fix
because the idea of removing human
agency in a life and death decision
remains regardless of whether you're
targeting a legitimate combatant or a
protected person
so they're the two prohibited categories
and then for those that aren't
prohibited we recommend a combination of
limitations on Youth and I should say
these actually reflect existing
constraints that militaries are using so
specifically the types of targets as I
said they're mostly used on on Military
objectives by Nature so incoming
projectiles enemy equipment things that
are stable in their characterization and
then limits on duration geographical
scope scale of use so enabling a level
of control over the effects
situations of use to constrain them to
areas where civilians aren't present to
reduce proportionality
difficulties and finally requirements
for human machine interaction so what I
mean there is about a level of human
supervision the ability to intervene and
deactivate so something like a
self-deactivation of the the machine is
not enough there needs to be a real
ability for the human to step in if
circumstances change so the this is our
our proposal to to reinforce and but
also to strengthen existing IHL in light
of the particular risks of autonomous
weapons thank you I'm sure colleagues
who want to unpack that later but thank
you I'll start with Dara okay mate um
and then come on to uh professional Bill
great thanks I fully agree that any tool
that can comply with IHL should be
prohibited I think the rules of IHL are
very are very clear on that and that has
to be the litmus test I think the other
element that I think is relatively
important is focusing on the
decision-making process surrounding the
the development of the tools and I think
we don't have a lot of guidance in that
regard what are the different factors
that we should take into account when
we're considering considering the tools
and it's something our colleague
mentioned earlier in terms of you know a
lot of the focus being on the process
and so ensuring that there's an adequate
process on the outset I think is really
important and it's something that we
haven't paid sufficient attention to so
far and they're drawing on a more
interdisciplinary approach you know
reading understanding the technological
constraints understanding how we ensure
legal compliance you know what other
issues should be taken into account I
think that'll be a really key key
component a mixture of
prohibition and regulation basically I
guess so yeah and guidance I think too
in terms yeah do you agree with that
professor
my
and it's not just in relation to this
question but whenever we're dealing with
a if it's new technologies or new
situations is to try and avoid saying we
need new law unless it is absolutely
imperative
um I I think one needs to keep in mind
that as soon as we say that existing
rules are insufficient we're effectively
admitting to Illegal Lacuna that could
be exploited by whether it's us or
others for the for years and it takes
years to develop new laws so I'm always
very very
um uneasy when we say we need new law
because what does it mean about what
we've got right now I also would tend to
agree with the um with the UK
government's position that by and large
existing IHL contains the basic rules
that we need here that doesn't mean that
we don't need to do a lot of work to
unpack and and guide how it applies to
particular situations I think in terms
of the categories that have been
mentioned that might need new regulation
um I I think you know we talk sometimes
about uh unpredictable uh but I'm not
sure if that's the test in terms of sort
of is it predictability that we need or
reliability right so think of existing
weapon systems that sort of loitering
systems for example that you might
release and it'll light in a particular
area and look for a certain signals say
if we're talking about attacking a radar
systems and and you can have a system
that you know that it's going to attack
certain type of thing but you don't know
which one you don't know which one and
you don't know if it might not find it
in self-destruct does that mean that
that system is unlawful or if I can tell
you I don't know exactly where it's
going to attack and I don't know the
minute is going to attack and I don't
know if it might decide to self-destruct
but I know that the only thing it can do
is something lawful and if not it will
self-destruct so I could you could argue
that that it's not predictable in terms
of I don't know you know exactly what
it's going to do but it's reliable right
uh and and so I'm not sure what
essentially we're supposed to be looking
for if we're talking about
unpredictability in terms of something
that will just go off and Target
whatever it likes then absolutely but I
don't I'm not sure we need new laws for
that I mean that that's under
host of IHL rules it would be unlawful
to use something like that and as far as
systems that are used against humans
again for me this is a technological
problem I I agree the systems right now
they can't they can't recognize you know
hostile intent they can't they can't
tell the difference right now between a
a short soldier with a real gun and a
child with a toy gun most systems still
aren't capable of of doing that or a
wounded soldier alive slumped over their
rifle versus a sniper lying on a you
know on the sniper rifle ready to shoot
they can't do that yet but that's a
technological problem and we shouldn't
use them because they can't be used
lawfully I'm not sure that it requires a
new law the the ethical issue is
completely separate there are absolutely
ethical questions there if we want to
create new laws because of ethical
concerns that is certainly valid but
it's not because of necessarily a legal
problem it's it's a choice thank you
Lord Kevin Jones who uh you you were
absolutely
um uh telepathic in your project of lots
of supplementaries I've got all brown
and Lord Hamilton and Lord Fairfax and I
think after that uh Lord grocott would
like to explore as it were the mirror
image of some of the constraint issues
that you've been outlining said Oprah
all right thank you little chair I mean
there's a certain irony and I was doing
having this conversation about Lacuna in
the law in relation to technology in
this Parliament at this time
because we are about to employ almost
all of our resource for about six months
trying to catch up with the risks that
we didn't engage with when we allowed
Technologies to be deployed into our
lives I mean Online safety bill which is
a large piece of legislation there's
only one of them
um there are a number of them in
different areas so
um
dealing with technology and regulation
has not proved to be
efficient or successful and it's caused
a lot of risk and and this is one of my
major concerns about the approach with
respect Professor Louisville that you
um encourage owners is that we
we are living now in a world in which
there are lethal autonomous weapons out
there they are being used for Century
purposes by certain people and if if the
evidence of the United Nations is
correct and there are uavs that have
been deployed and used that use them and
there is a kind of sense around the
the
way in which people talk about this in
this and recent Ireland that there is a
fear of losing out
you know among capabilities and there is
this constant argument that comes up and
arms control is why should the bad guys
have all the these weapon systems it's
not only them so I mean this may be a
for long attempt to try and do this but
I think those who were Keen to have this
select committee are trying to find a
way in which we can at least get in step
with this or get ahead and and actually
making making the mistake of banning
weapons now
prematurely would be I think the least
uh worst of the options so I mean how do
we um I mean what we're looking for are
recommendations as to how we can not
make that mistake again you know
entertain the risk and then find out
when it manifests so that it's much
worse than we thought it was
so what's so what from a legal
perspective given that we shouldn't be
showing people where the Lacuna are are
looking at in a legal laws but they know
[Music]
so what's your advice
please don't treat this as a three-hour
essay
part of what I think I was trying to say
is that the existing law is there you
know a lot of the problems have been
raised I just think are covered a lot of
the concerns are covered by existing
prohibitions so it's not you know it's
not to say that
um you know these things will be even
futuristic scenarios that are brought up
I still think are covered by and large
by existing rules
but as I said if we want to try and make
progress we need to unpack these rules
the rules are very general right
everything all the rules that we talk
about uh really once you try and apply
them to detail that's where things break
down and what's been happening and my
concern is even if we talk about a new
instrument if you look at say uh the
just just a few weeks ago the the
statement by the UK the US and others it
included you know draft articles on on
this subject now let's say that that
became the law
right because if you had new if you if
you had a new instrument it the phrasing
would be similar it would be at that
level it it sort of it it's at the
higher level right of of you know you
can do this you can't do that but it
ends up using phrases like and this is
you know phrases that have used been
used by the UK of
um say
um uh context appropriate human
involvement you know in in uh in the use
of weapons and phrases like that I use
and and they I think they're the correct
phrases but what does that mean
so how do you use them in this context
how to use them in that context what
does context appropriate human
involvement mean in the identification
of targets by by an AI system and
systems that are already starting to be
uh um looked at like a spotter and
squinter and and others that sort of
help detect objects right so what does
context appropriate human involvement
mean there as opposed to what does it
mean for the commander deploying a
system what will it mean when we have
systems that uh that engage swarm
technology right there there are so I
can lay out 20 different contexts and in
each one appropriate human involvement
might mean something else now if we had
a new instrument it wouldn't spell all
of that out it would still stay at a
relatively generalized level of you know
what the law is in terms of of whether
human involvement is needed or not but
we'd still need ultimately the guidance
on on what that means and so I think the
high level type of things that that we'd
end up with in new law I I think I think
we can find them in existing IHL what I
would urge us to do is to spend more
time on making this and how these things
would be used in practice in in the real
world that doesn't necessarily require
new law but it requires actually a lot
more work
Dr Murray yeah I agree I think the the
danger with with looking at a specific
type of weapon is that we missed the
bigger picture which is the more
pervasive
um role of AI across the military and so
I think the danger is that a lot of
regulatory efforts goes on addressing a
particular type of weapon the use of
which for the most part is probably
banned are regulated already under IHL
and then we make the same mistake I
guess as we've done with other areas of
technology is that we don't pay
sufficient attention to it we don't
think through the future consequences by
looking at the guidance and by working
it out and really thinking through the
decision-making process and for me
that's the big that's the big concern is
that if we only focus on a specific type
of autonomous weapon system we aren't
thinking through how intelligence is
generated using AI systems you know
which will affect targeting further down
the line our detention issues and I
think that's the big risk you know that
we kind of get distracted
do you have anything to add before I
bring in Lord Hamilton
uh just quickly on this issue of why
we're calling for new law
um because we we do agree that existing
IHL rules apply to autonomous weapons
and they already do constrain the use
and they would prohibit certain types in
particular inherently indiscriminate and
the icic does not often call for new
international rules for precisely the
reason that gnome has identified and we
don't do it lightly but I think we only
have to look at the debates in the CCW
which have been going on for nearly 10
years and we can see that states can and
they do hold different views about
precisely what are the limits and
requirements for the design and use of
autonomous weapons that flow from
existing IHL
I don't think this is surprising because
in every IHL expert discussion that we
have there's always points of difference
about not only the application of
different treaty obligations across
States because you have that but in the
precise interpretation of commonly
applicable key obligations and this is
not something that we can hope to solve
in a forum like the the CCW in fact
we're wary of trying to do that because
attempts to restate or reinterpret
existing rules
risk leading to sort of lowest common
denominator less protective formulations
so
actually the fact that we don't have
consensus on how the rules apply
specifically to autonomous weapons is
for us what makes it clear that we need
something specific uh we need something
that is shared and codified to provide
that understanding and Clarity uh so so
I think that's that's our rationale
there thank you very much Lord Hamilton
thank you Lord chairman um I'm a
shareholder in the herald Investment
Trust was apparently invests in
technology companies I've no idea what
they are and I'm a vice patron of the
Defense Forum my question is really for
Georgia Hines because we're talking here
about new laws which should be signed up
to by Western civilized countries where
professor lubels already referred to
hostile actors that sort of put a name
to hostile actor Russia and Vladimir
Putin he doesn't seem to be lying awake
at night worrying too much about
International treaties and whether he's
abiding by them and if we were to go to
war with Russia surely we would just
distinct disadvantage that he would be
using all these illegal systems against
us and we would have nothing to play
back to him does it not worry you that
we would be putting troops in the ground
at a distinct disadvantage to the enemy
that we were fighting
so I think I mean this argument comes up
a lot when we talk about International
humanitarian law but at the same time it
doesn't stop countries like the UK from
very clearly committing to abiding by
and following IHL and it's not based on
reciprocity it's based on the fact that
they abide by International humanitarian
law because that is who they are and
that is the standard that they want to
set now so I think as a general point
about International humanitarian law
it's not based on sort of what your
enemy does
now the point about uh you know the
majority of States actually what we saw
in the CCW two weeks ago was that the
majority of states were in favor of a
legally binding instrument so it wasn't
just a select uh group
um and so I think it is more
representative and broader than perhaps
might be implied with the question there
the other the thing I would say is that
the the adoption that is already
happening of national measures and
constraints is fantastic
but this is precisely our argument for
elevating it to a shared uh a codified
constraint in order to have that
commonality to have that more widely
binding aspect and and then to one
create Norms which is what happens with
international law even if ultimately you
have you know certain actors that do not
sign up to certain treaties this doesn't
prevent them from being transformed into
what's called customary International
humanitarian law which is binding them
regardless of if you have you know a few
who who don't attend so I think there
are a number of ways to sort of counter
that argument and also to say that you
know this is not unique to this issue
and it hasn't stopped the development
the progressive development of
international law and I think the
setting of stronger protections across
the board
thank you um Professor blue
Fairfax and then I'll come to Law Group
Cod I think my question may have sort of
been answered already or discussed
already but I'm going to ask it in any
event it's a question about
enforceability of Regulation
and in view of the comments
um Professor Rebel that you in
particular made you you said this is a
very everything is so fast moving in
this area
and given the uh difficulties we have
discussed about appropriate definition
um
and that also in your view said that it
is in your views likely there's going to
be a race to the bottom there's going to
be an AI arms race
and they have all those things I
I just wanted to ask about
um
the realistic Prospect of effective
enforceability of Regulation
and as I said Georgia if I may
call you Georgia and has sort I think
touched on that already but
I just wanted to hone in on effective
because if the genie is out of the
bottle already as has been suggested I
think by Lord Brown some of these things
right they're ready
um and I'm just concerned about
effective enforceability
realistic prospects of effective
enforceability I suppose it depends if
your concern is within forcibility once
particular systems are being used and
how they're being used and that would be
the same as the problems that we have
with with all sort of weapon systems and
actions in conflict and and uh potential
problems that come up that we see in
current conflicts now as well around
enforceability but that doesn't mean
that we don't that we don't try
um if you're talking about
enforceability in the sense of
let's say we try and sort of regulate
even the development of certain weapons
but yet some some others will will go
ahead and and use them I I think that is
a realistic concern I think there have
been over the years uh over the
centuries attempts to to to prohibit and
ban certain weapons completely
um sometimes they've been successful
uh it's interesting to to look at when
they've been successful and when not and
some some of this is linked to sort of
almost at the ethical moral social level
if you think about sort of gas and
chemical weapons and and so on that
seems so utterly abhorrent
um that that it's it's easier to to get
that prohibition I think it's a lot
trickier when it comes down to
technologies that militaries see as
being especially useful
um and they are usually less reluctant
to agree that to a um to a total ban and
so then you try and have sort of
regulations on particular types of of
uses of it that might be what could be
uh achieved here but again I'll just
come back to what I was saying earlier
in that I just think I I'm not
particularly you know I don't find it
disturbing other than the problem of of
of admitting that there's there may be
you know right now something that isn't
regulated which as I said strategically
just makes me very very nervous and and
I know in the icrc as they've said they
they usually don't like to say that
either so it actually means something
that the that in this case they they are
concerned that the law isn't there I but
beyond beyond that
um I just think even if we came up with
some kind of new
um treaty some kind of new instrument I
just don't see that it would actually
solve the problem of how we use these
things in practice if we would need
still the guidance that we need now on
spelling out as I said you know what
that means in particular context what
does human involvement mean what does
human control mean it's just it's a
phrase that's bandied about and it's
coming into all the various draft
instruments uh and you know I'm not sure
it would actually even solve the problem
maybe in Lord Horton just before I go to
Lord gray God yeah could I just ask I
don't know the degrees which uh any or
all of you been exposed to the emerging
UK mod policy on AI and weapon systems
but from everything you've said thus far
as I glanced down its headlines it seems
to be fully compliant with all your
concerns the fact that it would be
ambitious safe responsible that there is
absolutely no intention to deploy fully
autonomous weapons that there will
always be the requirement while
technology demands it that there is a
human in the system that is delegated
down so could you comment on the degree
to which
and this is comes to what George was
saying about the need for new law that
you think that the emerging UK mod
strategy on uh the use of AI is a common
is accommodating the concerns you have
about IHL
um already and therefore the residual
challenge is more one of how we continue
to engage the human dimension of
decision making at the appropriate
levels
so um
yes you are entirely correct and I think
from the from the perspective of the UK
as a state with a very um active
military presence on the world stage and
at the same time a public commitment to
IHL I think the position of the UK the
direction that it's taking is entirely
reasonable
um I think uh the the right things are
being said
um that that's that that's not the
problem from my perspective I I'm sure
colleagues on the panel here might might
see it differently but I you know I I
don't see that as being the issue for me
again it's it's what does this mean in
practice right it's just that we keep
having you know we have General
statements about things but what does
that mean I'm not sure that the work
from from
um and obviously there's a lot going on
uh to which I I'm not privy but but I
I'm not entirely convinced that enough
work is being done
on
actually sort of taking this down to to
the the various contexts I know there
are people within the system that are
interested in doing that I've spoken to
plenty of them over the last couple of
years and and so I I think it's spelling
out what it means in detail is the
problem not the the strategy not the
position
um and there are very specific problems
that we need to look at also we keep
focusing on the use rather than the
development the Weapons review process
for example how does that apply to AI
systems how do you use a Weapons review
process for for software uh this is not
just about AI it's about cyber as well
how do you use it when you know you're
you're examining whether something will
be lawful but the thing you're examining
will change constantly afterwards
sometimes even of its own accord so you
know at what stage you need to
re-examine its legality and so on is
there are complicated questions of how
we manage this but the headline strategy
uh I I find to be to be reasonable
absolutely
uh well I've been patient uh chairman
not least whether it's been extremely
interesting but um also because of a lot
of the area that's covered by the
question that I'm about to ask has has
been touched on it well quite frequently
actually but
um by the way I've got no relevant
interest to declare on this um but uh in
listening carefully to everything that's
been said I'm slightly alarmed in terms
of our report as of when it um is
produced because
um we've heard that it's very very
difficult if not impossible or maybe
unnecessary to Define what AWS is which
you know is a bit worrying if that's
what we're looking into and
um and the other thing that um that I'm
aware of is that um uh it was Georgia
Heinz that said this that so much of
this is about hypotheticals and um one
thing that politicians can't spend too
much time discussing is hypotheticals
you've actually got to make laws as or
participate in the making of laws
um so my question as it stands is are
there circumstances in which AWS could
improve compliance with International
Humanity humanitarian law now that's
been answered in part already but
because of my desire to get my feet if
no one else is back on the ground and
away from
um away from the eater could I ask
of specific examples where
um AWS could improve compliance with
International humanitarian law and
perhaps specifically to Georgia Heinz
who have found very very interesting
what you had to say about possible new
laws
the new laws as you spelled them at
potential new laws that you spelled out
would those prohibit
um any activities that are going on
present leaving aside for a moment how
you define AWS
um and can we can we just try and get it
down in terms of specifics
those are my two questions very good
all right Georgia Hines
thank you all right
um I will jump in there so in terms of
specific examples providing greater IHL
compliance
I honestly cannot give you any within
our definition so
um I think I can definitely give you
many that are currently being used that
improve military advantage and that you
know these um kind of air defense
systems that operate beyond the speed of
of humans I can absolutely see the
military Advantage there and we would
say they are currently being used within
IHL constraints
um based on those limits around the
types of targets the the limited scope
of uh time and duration
um Geographic scope all these kinds of
things so with those existing systems we
would say they are by and large from
what we know based on open source
information being used in compliance
with IHL and that is where we've drawn
the recommendations for our limitations
on use from
um as for whether our recommendations
would then prohibit any current
activities again we're a little bit
limited in our information because
obviously even with the icrc states
don't always want to share exactly the
extent of their capabilities and where
we are really running into problems with
this is there are technologies that
um uh operate on a Continuum so they're
either remotely piloted they're sort of
drone Technologies
um with the capability to operate in an
autonomous mode but we don't know
whether they are being operated in that
autonomous mode and I'm thinking
particularly in current conflicts there
are loitering Munitions so these are
sort of uh they look like drones and
essentially they're sometimes called
suicide drones will hover over a Target
and then dive and self-destruct
now
um we're seeing potential that these are
being used against human targets it's
unclear whether they are being used in
an autonomous mode or based on existing
remotely controlled Technologies and for
us this is a key consideration and and
so it makes it difficult to answer your
question as to whether our
recommendations would
um would extend to that but certainly if
these were being used as autonomous
weapons and were being used against
humans then that would be captured by
our prohibition recommendation the
others so the prohibition on
unpredictable systems is designed to
more capture the future Technologies
where there are grading integration of
machine learning systems that change
their functioning after use that gnome
was talking about that put them beyond
that human ability to predict the
effects swarm Technologies are another
one where at the moment they're being
run as remotely piloted the more
autonomous they become they start to
produce emergent behaviors they could
run into big becoming an unpredictable
system within our definition but on
existing use we've tried to base it so
that it doesn't actually constrain or
prohibit things that are already in use
and that are already being used in
compliance with IHL
thank you well our other two panelists
do you want to add to that or I guess
very briefly I think hypotheticals are
really the problem and I think that's
why focusing on the decision-making
process itself is is really useful
because it gives you a concrete way to
to think about the issues that arise I
think one of the issues is maybe that
we're operating under a slightly
different different definition
um and I think when I'm thinking of the
issue it's more thinking of how AI is
used and how it can it can benefit
rather than a fully autonomous system
that exists on its own and I think if an
AI system is used there are a number of
different ways where it could contribute
to to better compliance with with IHL I
think the ability to model predictive
consequences is a really good example
where you know you can use a system to
model to model sorry the likely effects
of an attack and to you know to draw on
past history to draw on the contextual
environments made the makeup of a
building you know to bring a lot more
intelligence to way to understand what
the consequences will be I just ask
whether anything is being developed
along those lines you're in the
hypotheticals now but is you know is
there a manufacturer somewhere in
Britain
um who's working
[Music]
um on that kind of equipment that you're
envisaging
there are projects being worked on with
regard to identification of objects for
example in a military context absolutely
there are there are projects and then
there's public knowledge of some of
these projects they're being done so so
for example
um if if these systems would be better
at identifying things than the current
systems that we've got
identifying what is military and what is
civilian now I'm not saying that they
are right this is but but again if we
talk about you know um possibilities I I
do think it's possible that you could
have systems
um that would have advantages also on
the humanitarian side again as I
mentioned earlier
side to it because when for example you
could be more accurate and only target
the military because uh because igl
allows some proportionate uh damage you
you could you could end up targeting
something that beforehand you wouldn't
have targeted because there would be too
much cholesterol harm now you can Target
with a small amount of collateral harm
and so therefore for for those people
that are in that small amount of
collateral harm they've actually now
suffered when beforehand the thing next
to them wouldn't have been targeted at
all because we didn't have anything
accurate enough so there's a flip side
to this but I I don't think uh for me I
don't think I could just say there'll
never be an advantage absolutely there
could be but it also depends on the
definitions so if you're a definitional
starting point is these systems are
systems that do all these kind of
unlawful things then of course you're
not going to have an example uh of of a
positive use of these systems because
you've defined them as as something
negative so it comes back to to how how
we Define them in the first place I
think it's important to to note and I I
mean I hesitate to to remind the the the
committee but of
the title for this committee is not
autonomous weapon systems it's
artificial intelligence in weapon
systems
right so in in that sense you have I I
would presume from from your own title
you have the Mandate uh to think about
things a little differently and not just
you know how do we Define autonomous
systems the way it's being discussed at
the CCW but to look more widely at the
use of artificial intelligence across
the uh the weapon systems and the
targeting cycle and someone shows that
title for a reason I hope not just
randomly I think that's advice very well
taken Professor
um what what I'd like to do is come to
Lord Hamilton for a moment and then with
Lord Brown's permission uh postpone the
the questions about International fora
because I think we might combine those
two questions and bring in the bishop on
uh the issue of accountability
um it strikes me that we've got an
enormous problem if we bring the law
into this because we can't actually
Define what we're trying to ban surely
we should be I mean the great advantage
of all of this is that we're talking
about military structures and they're
sort of the ideal pyramid aren't they
they have General Horton at the top and
everybody else all the way down
um surely we should be looking to
the responsibility should lie with the
military Commanders and what actually
happens with a weapon system whether
it's I AI or not and and place the
responsibility within the military
structure
and and to that extent you bring the
human element into it rather than try
and ban certain activities would you
agree with that personally
Professor
so yes I think accountability is is one
of the the biggest issues that keep
coming up and his rise to the most
concern
um I I think
pretty much everyone would agree that we
cannot have systems uh in use for which
there is no accountability I mean I I
that that's
you know I think that's a basic starting
point that nobody would would dispute I
think part of the problem with the
discussion around accountability goes
back to something I mentioned earlier
about the conflation of General Ai and
narrow Ai and these these being tools
and not agents right nobody's talking
about oh how do we hold the machine
accountable we're not going to hold a
machine accountable because you know
again this is not General AI Maybe
20 30 40 50 years but that's not the
kind of speculation we're engaging uh
with in in these debates so then we're
talking about a weapon system and if
it's a weapon system then accountability
I would argue the the problem has
perhaps been
made to seem more complicated than than
it is because accountability can be
determined the same way it is with any
other weapon system so and it's not
again a one-size-fits all because it
depends what went wrong so if you use an
AI driven weapon system and something
happens that looks like it may have been
a violation of IHL well you need to
investigate what what happened right you
know starting point we we and there's a
there's a obligation to investigate and
then you investigate if it turns out
that a commander deployed this system in
a manner that was against the rules uh
did it for example intently to harm
civilians or just as operating
instructions and and and and knowingly
used it in violation of those then you
can have responsibility of the commander
uh for that if the weapon is deployed in
accordance with with its operating
instructions with all the right
intentions and yet something still
happened then again the investor we do
the investigation to figure out what
that was it could be in a mechanical
failure we straight away go to you know
the out prison with the algorithms but
it could also be a loose wire
right in these systems you need to look
at that these things happen with other
weapon systems as well and we have
mechanisms for dealing with that if we
can't find a mechanical problem and we
don't know what happened and it's
something to do with the algorithms um
driving it um again that the
investigation continues if we if it's a
system where we can understand and you
know the black box is a problem but it's
not a problem with every single system
it's particular particularly with neural
networks deep learning and so on but not
always
so you investigate you look at also the
Computing side of it and if you can
figure out what went wrong you look to
see if it was a problem in the design of
it you look to see if it encountered
something it never counted and you can
try and understand and rectify that if
after looking at it you still can't
figure out what went wrong you know and
some it's you have this explainability
problem in the black box and you can't
figure out why it did it then you take
the weapon out of use you don't use a
weapon that that would be you know
unpredictable that causes these problems
and and if a commander
or a military will generally continues
to use a weapon knowing it malfunctions
and we don't know why it malfunctions
then there's accountability for that as
well as there is with using any weapon
knowingly uh that that could be
malfunctioning so I
I think we can find solutions to the
accountability problem along those along
those lines more generally on top of
which that's a focus on individual
accountability we also need to remember
that International humanitarian law is a
branch of public international law and
there is always State responsibility
regardless of what we find or don't find
with individual accountability
um Dr Mario and Georgia Hinds do you
want to add to that yeah I think just
very briefly I'd agree with the
distinction between General Ai and
narrow AI I think just to remind that AI
tools are complex systems but they're
made up of different components and each
component has a task and I think when
we're thinking about accountability we
need to look at those different
components you know having they been
designed and developed in a way that
they're capable of achieving that task
and then are they deployed in a manner
consistent with that task so you know
are they deployed in line with their
intended circumstances of use are
outside of it I think once we break down
the AI life cycle in that way it becomes
much easier to think about attributing
accountability and responsibility
because everybody has a role in the
system in some instances it'll be within
the military it might be as part of a
corporation you know if if tools are
used from outside but then it's just
understanding what the responsibility or
what the the component is intended to do
with each part of the life cycle put
your hands
uh yeah just quickly on this point so I
think a lot of our concerns around
accountability mirror our concerns at
the front end and this is where our
prohibition on unpredictable systems
plays a role because I think and gnome
has brought this up well about the black
box effect it doesn't appear with all
systems but for those systems where it
does appear I think we have a real
fundamental issue because for individual
criminal responsibility most systems
most legal systems require intent they
require a certain men's rare now if you
have a system that is producing its own
results outside of or continuing to
learn and to it might not be a
malfunction it might be what the system
uses and optimization but it produces a
result that is beyond a human intent
then you have a real fundamental break
with individual criminal responsibility
um I think you you will hear I think in
your next session from vanson from cypri
and they have done some very good work
in particular around accountability and
responsibility so they could speak much
more eloquently on this but they've
brought out issues around traceability
um and that means the ability to trace
the operation the performance the effect
of a weapon back to a human developer
and a user and I think there are there
are specifics around autonomous weapon
systems that don't arise with other
weapons
um the other thing that they have
suggested is having in contrast to other
weapons having a specific deemed scheme
of responsibility for those who are
involved in the development and use of
autonomous weapons and I think this
comes out a bit in annexe in the
ambitious safe responsible approach so
it says that the UK will clearly
establish authorities so accountability
and responsibility whenever UK forces
deploy weapon systems with AI and so
there's a question there about whether
that needs to be sort of AWS specific
with deemed responsibility on certain
operators where you can't otherwise
Trace back intention and things like
that whether that's fair and whether
that's something that military users
would accept is is a separate question
but that's a proposal that's been put
forward as well
at Bishop of Coventry
thank you Lord chair I I I think my
question has been largely
well addressed
um over over accountability but just to
um press it a little bit more and then
if I may
um ask her a slightly sort of wider
question that I think is related
um
I suppose it's to do with the question
well it's a number of things first
um whether
um this these methods of accountability
are
are going to suffice for the future now
that's such a difficult question but I
am uh I think little brown mix a very
important point and and Professor
lebelieu did at the beginning about the
pace of change and in a sense
um trying to think ahead
um so that that's one aspect is the are
the accountability systems that you're
talking about are they are they gonna
are they gonna last
um the the other and it's maybe this is
moving more into an observation but a
sort of interesting tension that I that
I think has been evident in in this
fascinating session and is relevant as
as as as as Dara Murray has pointed out
to our whole task is
I I I hear Georgia Hines talking about a
specificity about uh autonomous weapons
that moves things into a different Realm
ethically and legally
um
then the the the
AI that you are you know quite rightly
saying we must attend to AI across the
system
if I may add in the sort of
supplementary to that I
I I hear from Georgia Hines
um that
that the special specificity of of
lethal or autonomous weapons
does raise
um does touch upon a fundamental ethical
issue of
killing not being franchise to machines
and I just wondered whether you had any
Reflections on on that fundamental uh
issue and whether that is something that
needs to be addressed
um by our thinking I'm conscious of that
expression uh law is the hard edge of
Ethics if I've got that right you know
it's not unrelated to it it's where it
sort of comes down to the realities
who's going to that's a a challenging
brief who's going to uh to have a go at
unpacking it
professor
so uh just first on just on the
accountability and keeping up we will
need to keep up
but that doesn't mean that it can't be
done again so long as we're sticking
with narrow AI systems as long as we
haven't moved into the realm of systems
that set their own tasks right and then
go about achieving them
then we should be I mean the weapons
will get most of the systems will get
more sophisticated and we'll need to
keep updating our operating instructions
on their understanding for for everyone
in the field that's using them at every
single stage you know what that means
and what uh when and how they can be
used and when not and what the risks are
but we'll need to keep doing that but as
long as we do then the same basic
accountability
mechanisms uh I think should be in place
um in terms of the the specificity
of these systems well
I mean again for me it's less about the
autonomy it's more about the AI
um and and I keep coming back to and I
think um you know Dara's been saying
this as well I am just as much if not
more concerned by AI being used in the
early intelligence analysis
um stages that then feeds into something
that we think is completely done by
humans but it's actually all based on
information that was uh that was put
together uh by Ai and and the the two of
us together with a colleague from the US
are Ashley Dix a few years ago published
a paper where we looked at the the risks
of having some of these AI systems being
used in intelligence analysis for for
what we call the use adbellum the
decisions to go to war you know
self-defense right because I mean
ultimately the grander decisions we're
sitting here talking about what might
happen uh you know in a particular
military attack that involves a total of
you know 50 people or something but what
happens when our intelligence analysis
systems and War gaming I mean wargaming
has been done using computers for many
many years it gets more and more
sophisticated to actually go to war in
the first place is is is is is based to
a large part on intelligence analysis
done by AI systems you know but we're
not really talking about that you know
but it's so so the AI being used in
intelligence analysis and so on I think
is just as worrying
um and so for me it's less about the
autonomy it's more about the AI and as
far as the ethical questions
they're huge they are absolutely and I
don't deny any of them and I and I agree
with a lot of you know and some of the
concerns raised by the icfc and others
around the ethical side I think
absolutely these are concerns you know I
separate between can can we use these
things lawfully or not with existing law
and then questions of
um ethics but but the issue of AI
determining life and death decisions is
not unique to military contexts
right so self-driving cars were
mentioned earlier and the old-fashioned
it's almost you know a little cliche to
use it in some of these debates but the
old-fashioned philosophical trolley
problem right if you apply it with with
a self-driving car and you've got a car
that needs to decide you know now
there's only two options left because of
an oncoming truck and do I go up on the
Pavements and and run over these two
people or stay on the road and let the
passenger be killed and the car is going
to have to make that decision although
again I hesitate to use the decision in
the context of AI um but you know these
are life and death situations that AI
systems are going to do on a larger
scale traffic Management Systems being
done by AI is going to be you know
determining in from many countries a lot
more life and death situations than any
military Ai and that's without speaking
about Ai and health context and then
other contexts so AI is coming into into
critical life and death decisions across
every realm of society and I I am
actually concerned that we keep trying
to to debate it within the military
context as if this is something separate
and unique
and and we end up having a different
relationship to AI in the military
context as we do in others when that
same AI system or of different version
of it will make life and death decisions
or execute life and death functions
regularly in in other Realms and and I
think when we've not got enough joined
up thinking in that sense the people
debating it here need to be talking to
the people debating it there this is
this is much bigger about human machine
interaction and and how we incorporate
AI into our society across all Realms
and and that's where we need to be
having these big debates and then they
can feed back down into the military
side and and and into everywhere else we
need to understand ethically what what
our relationship is going to be with AI
and then think okay what does that mean
for the military what does that mean for
law enforcement what does that mean in
the health sector and then we might
think different things but I I'm
concerned that
we're having
sort of these these these big AI ethics
debate in in narrow silos rather than
joined up thinking thank you
thank you Sarah Murray and Georgia Hines
you have anything to add to that I think
I'll be very brief I think for the
foreseeable future we will be talking
about narrow Ai and so we will be
talking about systems that operate
within human defined parameters so the
accountability processes we're talking
about will be will be appropriate
excuse me I think my bigger concern is
with the use of AI in intelligence uh
decision making because intelligence
should hopefully provide everything that
the military does whereas the targeting
or the actual engagement is you know a
relatively small part so I think that it
has potentially bigger impacts on both
the military and the humanitarian
components than just the specific
engagement of targets and ethics is yeah
Way Beyond what you pay rate I think but
I think the the point about Healthcare
in particular is really is really well
made
Georgia Hines
uh look just to reiterate some of the
points I mean uh on accountability I
think yes we have existing systems for
individual and for State responsibility
um these will continue to operate but
with autonomous systems even if we're
talking about existing systems you can
still have at the moment they are say
for instance particularly vulnerable to
adversarial conditions so particularly
vulnerable to enemy interference or
spoofing as they call it now if this
produces unforeseen results who are we
tracing that back to so I think it does
actually bring in some different
considerations for accountability we can
talk about programmers and well you know
if there's a if there's a malfunction in
the code that's a program a
responsibility but the reality when we
talk to programmers is it's actually
very complex even in narrow Ai and that
they're not just it's one programmer
responsible for the whole piece of code
it's actually a you know a far more
complex and a process that involves many
many people who might only see a narrow
part of the development and then the
ultimate system then it's very very
difficult to have that traceability
which is something that cypri has said
specifically needs to be looked at for
autonomous systems thank you very much I
think little brown has got some
questions on International fora we've
been touching on uh in in the course of
the morning unless all your questions
have been answered Lord Brown well
they've all been touched them
and I I mean
I mean I think uh I think I think we
should at least tell our witnesses that
we've got the message about having a
broader look at this than only in
relation to autonomous weapon systems
um I mean it's undoubtedly the case that
AI is used in intelligence
reconnaissance surveillance and the
reporting of it is correct it's being
used in Ukraine significantly to effects
so
um I think it would be a mistake if we
didn't touch in that but but
but defense and security is special and
different because we train people
to exercise lethal force on other human
beings
and we do that to a limited extent and
our domestic security but we do it
um and and you know it's at the heart of
what we do when we create our military
military capabilities so it is special
and um and I actually don't make any
apology for finding myself in the same
space as the International Community has
in the autonomous weapon system and then
the issue of the interface between
humans and machines in decision making
about with the the use of lethal because
that's where the International Community
got itself I mean it went to this and
appropriately named convention on
certain Whatever It Is Well it's
actually its full title there's a
conventional prohibitions or
restrictions on the use of certain
Conventional Weapons and this is
important which may be deemed to be
excessively injurious or of
indiscriminate affairs
so so we went there and I think we went
there because of a hundred years history
of Arms Control
so I don't think this I mean this is
this this issue is a discussion about
International humanitarian law but
actually de facto
um is about arms control and whether we
can as we have done with many other
weapons of a subject to International
humanitarian law and could be deployed
consistently with International humanity
and come out of that discussion saying
we will not use them
right and we have been encouraged also
as legislators by many of the people who
have been responsible for the
development of AI enabling weapon
systems potentially to say don't do it
right so so so these questions really
are um I mean are we in are we in the
right place
in in in in doing that or other
alternatives
um is that likely to be successful
and if it's not likely to be successful
why is it not going to be successful
about these weapon systems when it has
been with a whole list of others
that were able to identify you know and
and in particular I'm interested in the
United Kingdom's position in relation to
this and your comments on that
I mean this has been an extraordinary
Rich
um session for us so I'm happy to I
think maybe I might start with the
Georgia Hines in this case and come to
you gentlemen
Georgia Hines
thanks very much for the very difficult
question
um
on where Where Do We Go From Here
essentially so yeah I mean two weeks ago
I've I've sat through the discussions in
the CCW but this has been going on for
nearly 10 years without reaching
consensus on the best ways to address
many of the risks that we've been
talking about today
um I think you know we were encouraged
in those discussions to see there have
been constructive moves we are talking
about substance and there are an
increasing number of states that clearly
recognize the risks recognize what's
being called this two-tier approach of
prohibitions on certain AWS restrictions
on the remainder recognize that there
are you know pragmatic principled ways
to articulate those limits
um but having said all that of course
there are still challenges within the
CCW and I think a lot will depend on the
next few months as the chair Works
towards a report I think for us the
bigger picture is the momentum towards
regulation and that includes discussions
occurring in other forums
um including with the UN General
Assembly first committee with the
resolution of uh 70 States last year
which the UK joined the Human Rights
Council is discussing it with a new
advisory committee looking at new
technologies brought broadly but with a
strong focus on autonomous weapons so we
think that the CCW remains you know a
strong forer that we will continue a
foreign to to engage in and in terms of
its history it does have a very good
track record that can be drawn on so for
instance you know the protocol on
um the use of mines and booby traps uh
the amended protocol 2 which which
ultimately you know then led to an
anti-personnel mind ban Convention as
well which uh coming back to one of the
earlier points that were made about well
what's the point if we don't have all
states joining this not all states are
party to the anti-personal mindband
convention for instance
that's not to say it's not effective
it's not to say that the UK doesn't say
it's effective either
um and and similarly with a lot of these
protocols under the the CCW so on
blinding laser weapons this was one of
the first that we saw that was a
Prohibition on a use of a weapon against
persons
um so you know this provides us with a
good precedent when we're talking about
autonomous so
I I'm afraid I can't give you a good
answer about why we were able to achieve
it more quickly with these other ones
than with autonomous weapons
um but I I hope that we can be
optimistic
um and at least as I said you know there
are discussions occurring in other
forums because I think it's good to have
you know multi-disciplinary it's good to
have
um different considerations of the issue
being looked at maybe not to be so
narrow
thank you professor lubell
um I I think it's
you can never rule anything out but I
don't think it's particularly likely
we'll see a new instrument a binding
instrument come out of the CCW
um for for reasons uh already previously
stated uh other forums May pick this up
and some are already including by the
way I don't think we mentioned Regional
forums you know you could could end up
seeing and there are discussions
happening
um as well that there may be
um things happening at that level but
you know what will we actually end up
with let's say we did end up with
something whether CCW or or elsewhere
you know what would it actually
um say I think you know you're not going
to end up with sort of total ban on
using AI because it's just too too
useful and states are too concerned over
others um using it and I don't think we
can equate it to some other things that
have been completely banned so we're
talking about regulations on on use that
that you know we might end up with and I
just don't see how anything in an
instrument form would get into much more
detail than what we're already seeing
come out in things like
um whether whether it's the the
statement by the UK and the us or the
icrc position you know and and they're
actually not as far apart as you you
might think you know there's there's a
lot of common ground there in terms of
you know accepting the need for human
control human involvement accountability
you know everyone's accepting all of
this
but at the instrument level it stays
very generalized and so I would just
remain with a concern that really what's
missing is the detailed guidance is the
unpacking
is you know when we talk about okay yes
that we all agree there needs to be
accountability okay how's that going to
work
right spell it out give details of how
accountability is going going to work a
context appropriate human involvement
what does that mean what does it mean in
this context what's it mean in that
context what's it mean for Intel what's
it mean for targeting right uh for this
technology what's it mean for that
technology and without that I'm
just you know it's for me it's not so
much a question of can we get an
instrument can't we get an instrument
it's what's this instrument actually
going to do unless
we have the the more in-depth discussion
Dr Murray yeah very quickly I think the
in-depth guidance is really key and I
think the other elements that might be
useful is to think through a framework
about how we approach the decision
making so something that was set out the
types of issues that should be taken
into consideration the the hurdles that
might be overcome that kind of more
practical guidance but potentially at an
international level might be really
useful because it might allow us to go
more in depth on specific issues
well thank you very much I'm going to
draw proceedings to a close now
um I think the three of you who've had
the great achievement this morning first
of all of answering a dazzling Rave
array of questions in a way that I think
we found hugely helpful but second also
in the process adding substantially to
the committee's agenda so I think we're
on both counts we are extremely grateful
to you thank you very much indeed thank
you thank you